hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new m1 powered macbook pro
and today we are going to be comparing
it against the previous intel powered
one now in yesterday's video
we compared the intel and apple macbook
airs
but today we are taking it to a whole
nother
pro level we're going to take a look at
photo editing
video editing we're going to look at
things like logic uh
xcode we're going to look at thermal
performance with our special
camera and much much more let's start
out by talking about the differences
on the exterior and they look basically
identical you can't really tell a
difference
except for this one little key
we have this little globe icon on there
if we hit it we get an emoji pop-up
just like on an ipad or an iphone
other than that they have the same touch
bars touch id
the display is identical and both have
just
two ports on the left hand side the
apple silicon macbook
does support usb 4 and both support
thunderbolt 3. now the keyboards are the
same
magic keyboards they feel great the
trackpads are the same
the webcams are still 720p but there is
new processing so let's compare them
this is the microphone and webcam
quality from the base 13-inch macbook
pro
that is powered by an intel processor
and this
is in a really nicely professionally lit
room so this is the best quality you can
expect from it and this is the
microphone and webcam
quality from the new m1 powered macbook
pro
let me know if there is any difference
in video quality
or microphone quality down in the
comments section below
now both of these are the base models
they have eight gigabytes of ram
of course the new m1 powered max they
are more efficient so we're going to see
how that affects the professional apps
now if you want to see a comparison
between
this 8 gigabyte model and a 16 gigabyte
model that we have coming in
make sure to click that subscribe button
and enable those notifications the first
test i'm going to run
is the ssd speed test apple said
that the new ssds are much faster even
though they're both 256 gigs
and as you guys can see yeah we
definitely
have a difference so looks like our
write speed
is literally twice as fast and as far as
the read speed it is 1.5 times faster
with the new m1 powered macbooks now
another interesting thing is that
amazon just discounted this brand new
macbook pro with apple silicon so if you
guys want to go and check it out
we'll have some links in the video
description to both of these now the
next performance test i'm going to run
is
uncompressing xcode this is a huge
file with lots of little files and i
hate on windows computers
having to wait for unzipping macs have
always been faster
but let's check out this new one it's
been a minute so far
and looks like the m1 mac is it's not
halfway there
but it's getting close and it's probably
more than twice as fast
as the previous intel one now the reason
i'm testing it is because
i was compressing xcode from the intel
mac and it took about a half
hour to compress which blew my mind it's
almost done uncompressing
and it looks like we're just over three
minutes bam
there you go that was three minutes and
three seconds
this one still has a little bit to go
and i'm gonna go ahead and try to
recompress it just to see how long that
will take
looks like the m1 powered mac is going
to take about 16
17 minutes to compress xcode
and the intel one took about 30 minutes
maybe slightly
longer looks like it is almost done here
all right five minutes and 48 seconds
compared to three minutes
and three seconds so that is a big
difference in performance
so that is almost twice as fast for
uncompressing
and twice as fast for compressing so
some of you guys are going to save a lot
of time
and now let's compare the cpu
performance using geekbench 5.
and we have our results and man i've
seen the results from the m1s already
but this doesn't get old as far as
single core score we went from 921
to 1726 and multi-core from 39.54 to
7533
that is 87 percent faster in single war
performance
so all the day-to-day small easy tasks
are going to be much snappier
and as far as multi-core score that is
90
faster so for heavy tasks photo editing
video editing rendering
man that's a huge difference and not
only that
this macbook pro the new one stayed
silent whereas the previous ones
i could hear the fans spinning up and
getting louder towards the end
and now let's go ahead and test out the
graphics in terms
of metal performance which more and more
apps are starting to use
the m1 mac is done already and this one
just got to 50
probably about 10 seconds after the new
mac finished
all right the intel mac is finished and
we have a massive
difference the new m1 powered macbook
pro
is over three times faster in terms of
metal graphics performance
now that is a massive difference but
this isn't the biggest thing
that is shocking me the biggest shocker
is that i just ran
the same version of geekbench 5 on my
16-inch macbook pro
and i got 22 500
it's barely slightly higher than this
1300
macbook pro this costs 2400 and it has a
dedicated graphics chip the 5300m
that uses about 40 watts of power
that is crazy so with graphics this
powerful
how does it do in terms of gaming that
is where this next test comes in i have
gfx bench
which is going to run a gaming benchmark
now in yesterday's video we actually did
some gaming on the macbook air
so if you guys want to see that you can
go and check it out of course these new
macbook pros
they have one extra graphics core at
least with the base
uh cpu and gpu combo all right we have
our results
and the intel macbook pro got 21.6
frames per second
compared to 77.75
so that is over three and a half times
better frame rate in terms of gaming
that is
crazy now you guys can check out the
macbook air video if you want to see the
results for the same test
and if you're interested in more gaming
tests we're gonna have a dedicated
actual gaming video for this machine so
make sure you guys are subscribed and
now
let's really push these cpus to their
limits and test out
thermal performance with our thermal
camera the first program i want to use
is cinebench r20 that is the
old one because i want to see the
performance if you're using applications
that haven't yet been optimized
so i'm going to go ahead and hit open
and you guys see it bouncing around down
there
that is rosetta translating the
application
so we can use it let's go ahead and
click run and as you guys might be able
to see
the processor is listed as virtual apple
not the m1 and interestingly it is
labeled at 2.4
gigahertz not 3.2 so let's go ahead and
let this surround and we'll check out
the performance we're about halfway
through the test
it looks like the hottest spot on the
intel macbook pros at 37
degrees celsius and oh look at that the
color is completely different
30 degrees celsius on the map
the pointer is actually jumping to the
other macbook pro
let's close it up 30 degrees celsius on
the m1 powered macbook
a little bit more than halfway through i
started hearing the fan on the intel
macbook pro
it's getting to about two-thirds now the
fan is almost
at full blast here starting to get loud
you guys can see right there it's about
to max
out whereas the apple silicon powered
one
it was completely silent i'm not sure if
the fan is running unfortunately i can't
tell yet because the software hasn't
been
optimized and look at that we are
actually almost done here
we are done and it looks like apple's
claims were
absolutely correct we have
2106 compared to 1580 so it looks like
the m1
powered macbook pro is over 30 faster
about 33
faster when it's running an app that's
not even designed for
arm it's running an intel based app
and for this score i know a lot of
people aren't even testing cinematic r20
so i wanted to check it out
it beats out even the 11th gen i7
intel processors the high score i've
seen for one of those
is like right at 2000 and this is when
it's
emulating running there so that is crazy
let's go ahead and close these and now
let's see what happens
when we're actually running an optimized
app this is cinebench r23 and not only
we're going to see the thermal
performance
and the final scores but i'm going to
take a look at the frequencies
in the wattage this is going to be very
interesting now obviously we can't use
intel power gadget so i have my own
terminal command that i'm going to test
right now and
let's go ahead and get started it looks
like right out of the gate
we are hitting almost 40 watts
on cpu power before it starts throttling
down
and then on our m1 powered mac
we are running at let's take a look 12.7
watts only let's take a look at the
latest update here
that's hard to believe okay 13 watts
it's running at
uh compared to hitting almost 40 and now
back up to 27
yeah 27.5 so right there you guys could
see
how this new macbook pro is going to get
a lot better battery life even when
you're maxing out
these systems not using just power
sipping different tasks
now this macbook pro is almost at 90 now
we're at 95 degrees celsius
the fans are starting to kick up and the
m1 is completely
silent and as far as performance this
first run is almost done
whereas our intel base one is maybe
two-thirds or so done maybe slightly
less
as far as frequencies our macbook is
staying at right around
3.2 3.1 and the wattage is still staying
at about 28 to 25 it keeps bouncing up
and down
where the m1 powered consistent 3.2
gigahertz
very similar but it's using 13 watts
instead now we're at 94 degrees our fan
is
maxed out i know if you guys can hear
that annoying wine we usually denoise
these videos
but that's a pretty big difference and
i'm curious if the m1
macbook pro will actually finish its
second run
before the intel does its first it looks
like it won't it's almost done here but
look how close that is
that is extremely close wait there
actually there's a chance
there's a okay no it didn't but it was
just what is that
three four seconds behind so it almost
lapped it
so it's been about seven and a half
minutes um the
m1 has already done five laps and is
beating
this one that is on three and a half
laps or so
and as far as thermals we're looking at
about a max of
43 degrees celsius on the intel you guys
can see all that heat
and then on the m1 we're looking at
about 38 degrees so it is cooler
and with that it is also i'm gonna pick
this up right here
wait is it completely silent which side
is a fan on
i know there's one fan in here the other
side
oh right here no no it's on this side i
feel the heat yeah i feel the heat
but you can't hear it i can't hear it
this one the intel powered one
after about two minutes i heard the fan
after four minutes it was maxed out
and ever since that point we're almost
done getting closer to 10 minutes it's
just
running at full blast and our cpu is at
90 degrees
celsius here and then as far as our
speeds we're still running at 3.1
gigahertz so the frequency is staying
about even
and the wattage is about 25 or so so
definitely a much hotter
much louder machine our timer's finished
cinematic r20
weights for the last run to finish but
they are both pretty close
i feel like this got through four runs
and this one got
through eight runs so basically double
the runs and here we have a score
and wow that is a pretty impressive
difference we have 39.19 compared to
77.34
and that is 97
faster basically twice as fast you guys
saw in cinebench r20
when we were running an intel mac it was
33 faster
very impressive but then with an
optimized app
that is double the performance and not
only that
this happened at about 12 to 13 watts of
cpu compared to 25 to 28
it also happened much cooler and
completely silently
which is mind blowing now let's get into
some
real world tests let's get into video
editing using final cut
i have the latest version 10.5 installed
and the first test that i'm going to run
is called the bruce x
this is going to see how well these
laptops both the cpu and the gpus
can render things like graphics color
corrections transitions
effects all those kind of things i have
background rendering turned off let's go
ahead and hit
save and i hit start here wow the apple
silicon is already at 50
compared to 15 on the intel base macbook
bam that okay that was quick i actually
missed it by a second
we're still at 39 here all right
bam we have a pretty dang big difference
so
this macbook pro using the latest
software uh latest final cut took
one minute and seven seconds
so 67 seconds actually before this
update it took
72 seconds so it got about five seconds
faster
whereas the new apple silicon macbook
pro took
just 22 seconds that is
just over three times faster graphics
rendering performance
and i guess apple said 2.9 times faster
so they
slightly understated it and this is
important because when you're video
editing
just cutting through the footage is one
thing but once you start adding color
corrections
you're starting adding luts effects
titles all that stuff
that is where the previous intel based
macbook pro really slowed
down so now let's go ahead and do
another test
with some actual 4k footage and see how
that compares this is 4k footage from
sony cameras footage that a lot of
people edit i'm going to go ahead and
hit
play and right away you guys can see how
that is
stuttering look at the little time code
here it is just skipping around because
we're dropping a lot of frames
our graphics card is completely maxed
out and so you guys could see that we're
having a really tough time
let's go ahead and see how our new m1
powered mac does
man a smooth ass butter look at that
perfectly smooth timing right here not a
single drop
frame we're using 74 percent of the
graphics only 33
of the cpu no issues whatsoever so if
previously you have to buy a 16-inch
macbook pro
to edit video but you wanted the smaller
size
well now you could sell that buy one of
these and make some money while you're
at it so next let's go ahead and export
this five-minute project
and see what kind of difference we get
okay this is just funny we're at 20
here 21 now 5 here
23 now this is still at 5
this is just embarrassing while we wait
i want to see if we have any differences
in terms of ram let me open up my
activity monitor
looks like on the m1 we have seven gigs
used compared to about
six but it also has less swap use
so both of them are using a lot of ram
basically using all of it i'm very
curious to see
what the difference we're gonna have
when we test out our same macbook pro
but it has 16 gigs
how much faster that will be so enable
those notifications
if you guys want to see it and we're
almost right here in time we're at 97
this is not even at 25 yet all right i
laughed the timer let's wait for this
one
okay finally we're at 99
done that took way too long i kept
leaving
and i kept coming back and checking up
on it 12 minutes
and 57 seconds take a guess
how long the apple silicon macbook took
in the comments below pause this video
for now
it took three minutes in 19
seconds that is 3.9
times faster massive difference and that
performance
is nearing or maybe even beating the
16-inch macbook pro
i think now i absolutely have to compare
this 13 inch
to the 16 inch base model now of course
we are using final cut it is really well
optimized
and so if you're interested in davinci
resolve which does have a beta for arm
the apple silicon max and premiere pro
which is not yet
optimized who knows how long that will
take i'm going to be doing a comparison
diving really deep into video editing on
my personal channel i'll go ahead and
leave a link down in the video
description if you guys want to check it
out
next i'm going to jump into photo
editing but first i want to mention
battery life of course apple silicon not
only is much faster it's a lot more
efficient
and i just noticed that i'm going to be
needing to plug in this intel
mac in it has 19 battery
and our m1 powered mac has 50
now here is the real kicker when we
started this video
the intel mac was 100 charged the
arm one the apple silicon was at 80
percent
so this started at 20 disadvantage after
we've been running all these tests we've
actually been running even more tests
and downloads and
installs on this it's at 50 compared to
19.
that is incredible getting into photo
editing this is
lightroom classic i'm going to go ahead
and go over to the develop page here
and one thing to note is that this is
not an arm optimized
app we're using rosetta to run this this
is an intel based app
so let's see what performance we get
while we're waiting for adobe
to optimize these so here's the exposure
slider
that is insanely smooth and let's test
it on
this intel one i don't know if it's me i
mean i don't want to be biased
okay i'm not gonna say it's less smooth
but both are smooth there
let's go ahead and try to punch in
wow okay now let's go ahead and switch
photos
okay do you see the m1 powered mac
faster slightly faster but it is faster
and it's running off of rosetta it
literally is faster i was expecting it
to be
slower but still usable look at that
oh is this one slowing down i don't know
if it's ram is getting full
oh no it's getting hot the cpu is
getting hot so the performance is
getting worse
we'll do a quick brush test here we get
a little bit of lag
at the start let's try on the m1 powered
also slight lag right when we start but
then after that
look at that basically perfectly smooth
okay
so we have 50 42 megapixel images here
let's go ahead and export these and see
what difference we get
all right the new mac is almost done it
looks like it's done okay bam
right there this still has a little bit
to go but
after about 20 or so the fans kicked up
and they're just running at full blast
okay and we are done with the intel
based mac we'll let it cool down here
so the intel base mac took four minutes
in
eight seconds to export 50 of these
images
the m1 apple silicon powered macbook pro
took two minutes and 53 seconds
that is 43 faster
huge improvement but keep this in mind
lightroom classic right now is not
running normally
it's not optimized it's running as an
intel app
with rosetta now along with that i want
to mention two things first off
um we know that lightroom is really
limited by ram
for example our 8 core brand new 2020
imac
that took 3 minutes and 55 seconds with
eight gigs of ram
so this macbook pro wasn't that much
slower even though at half the cores
now how in the world is the m1 powered
macbook pro
running it so much faster also with
eight gigs of ram
my thought is that the ram that's in
here the unified ram as apple calls it
is just way more efficient being right
there in that same
chipset and now for those of you guys
that work with music we're gonna test
out
logic we have a benchmark here with a
bunch of tracks we're going to start out
with
80 different tracks enabled and see how
these
stack up let's go ahead and hit play
here
okay while the m1 power mac is going
this one overloaded so this little uh
test is 30 seconds long i'm gonna let it
run
that's at 84 percent and i'll disable
some tracks on the intel powered mac
so it looks like the m1 is handling 80
tracks just fine it's almost done
playing through
and the intel one is even overloading
with 10 tracks now now buteem actually
tested this
out on the macbook air with intel
processor
that got eight no don't tell me you
can't do eight
okay let's try that again
my is it because the cpu is hot i don't
know why it keeps crashing on me
maybe there's some background task
running and that's why it's not being
able
being able to handle six or seven that
was
four right there technically if
everything is running smooth you have
anything in the background maybe you can
handle about 10 tracks
obviously with the m1 powered mac with
logic optimized
for apple silicon it's running insanely
fast it just did
80. let's try 100 on the m1 powered mac
so far oh okay it did crash there the
macbook air handled
94 tracks with the m1 processor same
processor so this one couldn't do 100
i have 94 set right here and i'm sure it
can pull off the 94.
this is interesting i'm actually hearing
the fan
for the first time maybe because this
one's getting quiet now
yeah i didn't hear it before video
editing i guess we're pushing this to
its limits
you can safely save 94 95 tracks in
logic
compared to 6 to 10 the 2020 5k
8 core imac handled 125
and this macbook pro is not there but
very close
running on battery power that is
impressive and now for all of the coders
out there we are going to compare
running x code i have a benchmark right
here and it has its own timer
i'm gonna go ahead and open it up all
right and now i'm gonna hit command b
to run and let's test this one too
all right let's go interesting the new
macbook pro even though we started it
later
is a fair bit ahead right now and both
laptops are maxed out with 100
cpu usage the intel based macbook pros
fans are ramping up i can hear them now
and it's at 93
degrees celsius all right unfortunately
the build failed on our new mac and it
also failed on the old mac
now maxim erimenko made this benchmark
for us we've been using it with the
older max
maybe it's just the new version of xcode
something needs to be
fixed or changed we don't do any coding
so we're going to go ahead and contact
him and see if there's an updated
benchmark that we can run for you guys
and then we will revisit this but as far
as just
how fast it was moving through we saw
that the m1 macbook pro was moving
through much quicker until it reached
that point
where they ended up both failing all
right guys let me know what you think
death of intel death sell your intel
stock
maybe you do want to sell your intel
stock this was an
experience the macbook air video was
great this one we dived
much deeper into pro apps and couple
things really surprised me one of course
the performance
is awesome in the apple silicon
optimized applications on top of that
for the applications that haven't even
been updated yet
it still was way faster so our previous
thoughts
of you know if you need applications for
intel you're professional worker you
want to wait maybe a year
it doesn't seem so it is just working so
well nothing like
the windows arm devices that we tested
that is
incredible and on top of that the
thermal performance
is insane we're going from loud fans 9
500 degrees celsius
to completely silent we don't know the
temperatures yet
as far as the internal cpu temps
hopefully some of the software will get
updated we will revisit that in our
review
but it is just incredible and now i
really have just two thoughts
first off if the thermal performance is
this good
how is this macbook pro gonna compare to
the macbook air that's also m1 power
that's less expensive
some of you guys like the design better
i'm really excited to
compare this macbook pro against the
macbook air
that's going to be a video we're going
to work on and then also
what if we have 16 gigs of ram in this
machine how are some of those
professional apps going
to perform so we will be working on that
video
today make sure you guys have those
notifications enabled because we have
some great content coming up
thank you guys for watching and once
again you can pick up one of these on
amazon
discounted right now it's crazy if they
already have a sale on it go check out
the links in the video description click
that circle above if you guys want to
subscribe
and if you want to see another great
video especially how this does in terms
of video editing
in premiere pro davinci resolve we have
it over there
as well as our buyer's guide thank you
guys for watching this one max and i'll
see you in the next video